you
okay this is my nemesis computer
impossible and I'm going to give it a go
here trying to beat him I've only ever
beat the computer once while I was
recording so let's see if we could get
another one in here so we have an
exchange Queen's Gambit exchange and I'm
gonna try to be really solid and just go
from here trade a little bit and
eventually get my rook on the e-file and
I have to be aware of this central
expansion that it could be going forward
with and before it gets the Bishop to d3
I think I better make sure I get my
Bishop to d3 welcome to some exchanges
here and now we're gonna have this
temple gaining move not really a whole
lot I could do about it
I wonder if Knight d7 or Knight to f6 I
don't think he has another choice when I
go here maybe I could go with my king
Knight to one of these two let's back up
and this is a very sensitive Square this
is gonna be a pain I think I need to I
can't allow that space gaining move with
h5 and I think it moves every three
seconds so not a whole lot of time I
better take if I go here Bishop takes
maybe that's a possibility actually no I
better not go with that
see if night here Bishop takes I'd have
to take my queen to cover this and then
Queen b3 is very uncomfortable so now I
think I play here Knight to e7 I need to
watch over this f5 square and if I
Castle I'm dropping this pawn so I think
I might need to devote another move but
first let me get this night working he
wasn't doing anything
so this central expansion by the way I
don't think you could be doing that now
I could castle
because of my pressure I like this
because of the pressure on g3 I don't
have to worry about this f3 for at least
not right now but maybe it's being
prepped with this last move and we're
gonna see and let me I don't think that
this is a bad move to go forward with I
think I want to improve my King position
just a little bit watch out for any
tricky stuff here this square two
knights on that point and I guess
there's maybe some lateral movement here
I could always back up with my queen
this tends to be a very good square for
a knight
I don't know if I could really manage
that though see it really doesn't have
any play but not sure I have any play
either
let's seem like g4 okay yeah there's
gonna be some sacrifices over here I
have to be very cautious I want to trade
one night I'd really be happy if I could
trade one night I think he could do a
better job he's kind of he's garbage
right now so let's let's improve the
worst placed piece let's get this guy
working and I think I could get this in
one of the benefits you'll notice is
that he covers a base point he's very
active there's not going to be an
accident over here on h5 is there so I
think I did well with that regrouping
but now this nights gonna have some
ideas of coming into this square so
maybe I need to scoot over let's scoot
over somewhere maybe I could be
successful finally maybe I want to trade
here let's let's do this you can go to
one of these two it is a he I always I
always say this so so finally I could
get this night out yes I think so
hopefully nothing nothing happens bad
over here so let's take here I don't
want I want to keep the structure as is
see it really doesn't have anything it
really does and it's just it's just
fishing for stuff there's nothing here
okay yes no now I want to do what I
don't my queen tethered to the defense
of this pond I gotta go quick
this looks really silly but I'm gonna do
it
there might be something bad happening
here okay
and now how could I get rid of their
night okay I have an idea I hope I'm not
missing anything I want to get my Knight
to g4 a queen tried I love Queen trades
let's go for that so I'm actually very
comfortable I think something bad gonna
happen here oh let me just cover stuff
no I really like my night here let's do
this something could happen here there's
three pieces hitting it yes and there it
is okay so look at all the pawns it ends
up getting ah okay I think the most
important one - hang on - oh I don't
know I want to hang on to my rook pawn
let's try that okay so now maybe I could
get this I want to get to b7 let's
attack that rook I got to get my king
position he's stupid
I have a stupid King position a minute
nine also not the not a lot of time so
much for my king position huh did I just
give that pawn back
oh really no it's very tricky it's very
tricky and where's mine I have to go oh
what a garbage square he's got to go
back home
45 seconds oh my knight is so pathetic
yes he is Wow
what a bad night he is terrible
yeah this is trouble 39 seconds oh I
have to go here 36 seconds I get this oh
I think I have it sort of well I kind of
have this know what a tricky move gotta
go here I'm dropping every pawn gotta
get this pun if he gets my pawn I get
this center punt I gotta get that guy I
think it's I think it's pretty good here
could I get a perpetual
or as a perpetual no it's not really
working gotta go quick
where are the quick moves I don't really
have any quick moves come on maybe I
could offer to draw oh this is a draw
this is a trial take a draw draw offer
offer a drop drop yes I'll take the draw
oh my goodness um I've noticed that in
many games the the knight he's just
garbage I often say that he's very
tricky but he's often very garbage like
he's expendable
to be to be a bit more serious about it
he's expendable and if you get two ponds
for night it's still just very very
difficult he wasn't doing anything I had
to sacrifice him back in the end but I'm
actually very happy to get away with the
draw against this beast and we'll see
what happens the next time I play but
that's all for this video I hope you
enjoyed it
take care bye
you